すご！
これ、 撮ってもいいんですか？
いいですよぉ
すご～い！
事前調査にお越ｓｓ.
お越しいただい..来ておりま～す
ううわｗ
すぅｇ、、、えぇぇ、、、
うわｗ俺よりでかい、、、
うえｗでかいｗ
すごいｗｗ
あやばいちょっと毛穴がｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
これ着ますもんね当日
スタッフ）はい着ます
わーわーすごいすごいすごい！
もうこっからですもんね
じゃあ、、はフェの中に行ってみましょう
すごっ！ｗ
ずっと俺んちにいないと思ったでしょ
ずっとあそこにいたんですよ
恥ずかしいなぁ、、
うわぁああぁ、、、
あぁ、、
あぁぁ、、
あーあーあぁ、、
ｗｗｗｗははｗｗ
すごいなぁもう俺だらけだな
アイドルかてｗ
わぁヒカキンさんだびっくりした
なんか昔の動画を
僕がなんかレビューする
ていう動画が流れてます
左上で僕が見て
過去になんか人気だった動画を
一緒に見るというシステム
ちょネーミングセンスをうたわれ、、
ネーミングセンスを疑われそうなんですけど
このパンケーキとか所沢が印刷されてるんで
是非是非食べてみて欲しいと思っております
わもう一品目が来た
あーありがとうございます！
うん
普通にうまいｗ
スタッフ）どんどん、、じゃあ置いちゃいますね
心の声）まじうめえええええ！！
心の声）けど一人でいるからあまり大きい声でいえねぇ、、、
うん
飲みやすいな
は）食べよーや
は）あっちに、あるので
よ）食べましょーや
は）せっかく来たから
よ）あ！第１名！
は）や、ほんと！第１名！
よ）よし。
は）スマホモンスターが作った
青いキラメキを放ちつつも
さわやかな味わいを楽しめるサイダー。
よ）おー！
よ）ダァッ！
は）んー！
よ）美味しいですか？
よ）それではいただきまーす
よ）あー！
よ）あ、おいしい！
は）美味しいでしょ？
よ）うん。おいしいおいしい。
は）そういうことよ。結局。
よ）うん！めっちゃくちゃ美味しいです！
は）スナックもあるんで
よ）あすごーい！
は）ぜひぜひ！これあの、、、
よ）はフェ！
は）俺のオススメのトマトソースだから
は）そうポッキーとかちょっとつけて食べてみ
よ）あー！
よ）よし。じゃあいきますよー？
よ）いただきまーす
（カリッ☆）
は）ｗｗｗｗｗははｗｗ
は）あっははｗｗｗｗｗ
よ）ぉおあああぁぁぁ！！！！！
よ）デスソースゥ？！！？これ！
は）ううん？ｗ
は）トマトソース、トマトソース。ｗｗ
よ）いやデスソースでしょこれ！！
よ）うううTT
は）トマトソースだよ
よ）ちょっとこれカラッ、、、、
よ）あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛！！
は）ぱぁぁぁぁぁぁ！！！！！
よ）っふっはっはっはｗｗｗｗ
は）やばいやばい
よ）え、これ商品化するんすか？
は）うん
よ）え、まじすか！？
よ）え、それまじですか？
よ）コレ本当に？
よ）コレ商品化する！？ｗｗｗ
よ）ばかでしょｗｗｗばかばかｗｗｗｗ
よ）うーわ！
よ）ちょっと、え、そんなんあるんすかマジで
は）あるよぉ！！！
よ）本当だデスソース付きって書いてあるマジだ！
よ）えーこれマジで！Ｗ
は）はい、というわけで
は）えー、はフェ！
は）いつまででしたっけ、、
は）ぅおぉえ！！！
は）はい！というわけで、はフェ
は）ハアァァァ！！！
は）えー6月にじゅうしち゛ぃぅ、、、、
は）まで！ｗ
は）原宿でやっておりますので
是非みなさん来てくださいね～！
は、よ）いぇーい　ばいばいーい
は）はいｗ
よ）ねえぇちょっと無理だって！！